bon sens nous sommes le mercredi à 6
avril merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
hier soir saint quentin en yvelines
organisé sa première soirée des
entrepreneurs avec ses douze communes et
plus de 1000 seize mille entreprises l
agglomération espère attirer de nouveaux
acteurs économiques sur le territoire
retour sur cette soirée à suivre et
benoît hamon s'est exprimé hier soir sur
le projet de loi travail le texte
examiné en ce moment à l'assemblée
nationale cristallise toujours les
mécontentements
une réunion publique était organisée
pour l'occasion à trappes afin
d'échanger avec les habitants sur le
texte est notre invité ce soir en
plateau jean marc andré bâtonnier de
l'ordre des avocats de versailles
menaces sur les libertés fondamentales
abus dans les perquisitions
le représentant des avocats s'alarme sur
l'état d'urgence promo j'ai récemment il
reviendra avec nous sur la situation
actuelle politique pour commencer et de
12 ils sont donc 12 depuis hier à
prétendre à la primaire organisée par la
droite en vue de la présidentielle 2017
jacques myard député des yvelines maire
de maisons laffitte a annoncé sa
candidature et il entend poser la
question de la souveraineté de la france
déjà surnommé le donateur comme peu
français l'élu des républicains a
souvent fait parler de lui pour ses
déclarations jugées sexistes voire
parfois même homophobes en février 2015
il avait également fait polémique en
allant rencontrer bachar al assad
la primaire je le rappelle se déroulera
en novembre tous les candidats doivent
cependant obtenir avant septembre les
parrainages de 2500 adhérents des
républicains dont au moins 250 élus et
je vous le disais en titre hier soir
saint quentin en yvelines organisait sa
première grande soirée des entrepreneurs
initialement prévu en novembre
cet événement avait dû être reportée en
raison des attentats un rade en un
rendez-vous pardon qui a rassemblé de
nombreux chefs d'entreprises du
territoire
l'objectif comprendre leurs attentes et
présenté les nouveaux axes de
développement économique de saint
quentin en yvelines camy lambert nous en
dit plus nous pouvons être fiers des
cézeaux 1600 entreprises
installé sur notre territoire avec des
leaders dans de nombreux domaines
il est classé parmi les huit zones les
plus innovantes du monde le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines a rendu
hommage à ces entreprises
mardi 5 avril le théâtre national a
accueilli plus de 600 personnes pour la
grande soirée des entrepreneurs on doit
tous sauvés sur ce pays en sera sûrement
beaucoup plus derrière la logique de
l'entreprise
la création de richesses et de viser une
hyper croissance de 3 4%
et là on pourra dire que la france doit
retrouver son rang son niveau d'emploi
son niveau de vie voire de chasse ça
vient aussi la pression des fans voilà
ce que parce qu'on a un petit faire
passer ce soir la majorité des invités
présents dans la salle étaient des chefs
d'entreprise ils ont répondu à plusieurs
sondages afin de comprendre leurs
attentes
invité d'honneur de cette soirée valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france
moi je souhaite refaire de l'île de
france une collectivité d'investissement
parce que c'est de ça dont vous avez
besoin des pôles attractifs dans
lesquels on trouve ce carré magique
entreprises formation logement transport
c'est ça que la région peut vous offrir
olivier dassault industrielle est député
et xavier fontanet ex pdg d'essilor et
professeur à hec ont également fait le
déplacement dans leurs discours ils ont
évoqué la réussite du canada et de
l'allemagne pour sortir du marasme
économique de son côté la communauté
d'agglomération a fait savoir son
soutien notamment en termes
d'infrastructures de fiscalité et de
formation pour accompagner au mieux la
création d'entreprise on récompense les
bonnes pratiques on montre les jeunes
radicaux récompensions renforce
on est là pour les accompagner la soirée
s'est terminée avec les récompenses du
premier festival du film d'entreprise
dans les prochaines années
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ambitionne de
devenir la silicon valley française est
l'événement n'était pas prévu hier soir
il ya une manifestation surprise
organisée par la cgt différents
syndicats étudiants mais aussi plusieurs
élus de l'opposition de saint quentin en
oeuvre
de la soirée des entrepreneurs organisée
au théâtre saint quentin en yvelines ils
en ont profité pour interpeller les élus
et les employeurs sur le projet de votre
travail en manifestant à l'entrée du
théâtre pendant une partie de la soirée
comme vous pouvez le voir écouter ces
précisions recueillies au micro de
william ce qu'on conteste c'est
effectivement un tous les cadeaux qui
sont faits au patronat les exonérations
de cotisations sociales ou les lois qui
permettent aux employeurs de
flexibiliser encore plus alors qu'on a
déjà énormément de salariés qui
souffrent de l'intensification du
travail des horaires décalés des heures
sup à n'en plus finir et aujourd'hui on
a un mouvement qui se construisent pour
le rejet de la précarité des mauvaises
conditions de travail des bas salaires
donc on est venu se faire entendre des
ennemis des patrons est donc celui qui
m'ont très symbolique que le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en haut lieu
de culture tient des rares à avoir été
épargné par la carcasse des subventions
de l'année dernière on organise
aujourd'hui un grand raout pour tous le
patronat local et de à base de petits
fours alors que dans la rue les gens se
battent pour leurs droits
et alors que l'examen du projet doit
travailler a débuté à l'assemblée
nationale de nombreuses organisations
syndicales continuent à s'opposer à ce
texte le député benoît hamon a décidé
d'organiser hier soir une réunion
publique à trappes l'objectif pour le
député des yvelines échanger avec les
habitants sur ce texte mais aussi
éclaircir certains points avec l'aide
d'un inspecteur du travail les
précisions de williams elle va faciliter
le recours aux heures supplémentaires
sans même qu'il y est c'est un sujet qui
rassemble mais qui questionnent ils
étaient une centaine mardi soir à
trappes venu chercher réponses à leurs
interrogations sur le projet de loi
travail
une réunion publique organisée par
benoît hamon pourrait changer mais
surtout décrypter certains pointent
souvent mal interprété les médias en
général parle que de deux points les
apprentis mineurs et puis des indemnités
de licenciement donc le gouvernement à
reculer sur les apprentis mineurs
toutefois il ya beaucoup d'autres choses
dans cette loi notamment un des fils
rouges qui est l'inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes
ça veut dire que l'accord d'entreprise
pourrait primer sur l'accord de branche
le contrat de travail qui peut être mis
à mal et puis la mise à mal aussi du
principe de faveur aux minots
les deux hommes vont analyser chaque
article du texte présentait expliquer
objectivement par l'inspecteur du
travail
benoît un mondain ensuite sa position
pour lui certains articles sont à garder
comme le compte personnel d'activité où
le droit à la déconnexion
mais le texte doit être réécrit le fait
que désormais la loi ne soit plus le
socle qui protège mais qu'un simple
accord d'entreprise puissent créer un
droit du travail moins favorable que la
loi c'est à dire qu'en gros à chaque
entreprise
il y ait son propre code du travail tout
ça et mon avis et va être très négatifs
et ne garantit absolument pas les
créations d'emploi ça la raison pour
laquelle j'espère que ce texte sera
retiré pour être substituée ou alors
profondément remanié au menu des
propositions à inscrire dans la loi la
reconnaissance du burn out sujet cher à
benoît hamon après l'oise et l'essonne
c'est la troisième réunion publique
organisée par le député
prenons à présent la direction de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une conférence
débat sur la thématique la liberté
sécurité et est organisé dans un
amphithéâtre de la faculté de droit et
de sciences politiques à lyon court
michel tubiana président d'honneur de la
ligue des droits de l'homme étaient
présents à cette occasion pour débattre
pendant plus de deux heures avec une
vingtaine et des types d'étudiants il
était temps micro de notre journaliste
et metella et demi d'euros après chaque
grand événement comme les attentats de
new york comme les attentats de paris
un peu plus de mesures de contrôle un
peu plus de mesures drastiques un peu
moins de liberté au prétexte nous disons
nous dit-on d'une amélioration de la
sécurité ou pour garantir notre sécurité
lorsque je constate et chacun peut le
constater c'est que les lois s'empilent
les mesures restrictives de liberté sans
piles et en même temps la sécurité n'est
pas
systématiquement là et nous accueillons
en plateau ce soir jean marc andré
bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats de
versailles jean sera vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous avez été
nommé bâtonnier en décembre dernier vous
avez 48 ans et vous avez fait vos débuts
en tant qu'avocat dans un cabinet à
saint quentin en yvelines
je me tourne le faire alors nous
revenons d'abord sur l'actualité vous
êtes récemment exprimé sur vos craintes
concernant la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence alors la fin du mois de
février l'état d'urgence a été reconduit
jusqu'au mois de mai qu'est-ce qui vous
inquiète spécifiquement dans cette
décision du gouvernement ce qui m'a qui
est a priori je pense que je ne suis pas
le seul c'est que l'état d'urgence par
définition doit demeurer quelque chose
d'exceptionnel sur une période
déterminée et on voit bien aujourd'hui
notamment que les dernières déclarations
notamment de monsieur le foll que on
risque de prolonger encore cet état
d'urgence au delà du 26 mai prochain
compte tenu de l'euro ce qui est
embêtant c'est qu'on sait très bien que
dans le cas de cet état d'urgence
les résultats ont été significatifs dans
les quinze premiers jours dans les trois
premières semaines
aujourd'hui le risque c'est de
pérenniser des mesures d'exception dans
le cadre du droit comme du droit commun
et donc de faire en sorte que
l'exception devienne la règle et non
plus l'exception alors à la lumière des
derniers événements qui se sont déroulés
donc à bruxelles le 22 mars dernier les
attentats donc dans la capitale belge
qui ont fait 32 morts je le rappelle est
près de 340 blessés il est normal que
l'état français redouble de vigilance
l'état d'urgence paraît donc inévitable
ça a permis aussi de faire des
arrestations des perquisitions notamment
à argenteuil je pense oui il ya eu des
arrestations il ya eu des perquisitions
mais la commission de parlementaires de
contrôle vient encore de le démontrer
aujourd'hui les mesures propres à l'état
d'urgence ne sont plus un gage
d'efficacité pour la protection des
citoyens donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
aurait fallu de mon point de vue en tout
cas arrêter l'état d'urgence je pense
avant l'expiration des trois premiers
mois
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se rend bien
compte que politiquement aussi qui va
oser qui prend le risque de suspendre
d'arrêter l'état d'urgence si 48 heures
après quelques jours après
nouveaux incidents malheureusement
devait devait intervenir sur le
territoire dont je crois que on est
parti pour un état d'urgence qui risque
de rester la règle et d'être pérennisée
sans qu'il y ait vraiment de résultats
concrets sur la sécurité des citoyens
mais quels sont les autres solutions
dans ce cas là parce qu est ce qu ont
assez d'armes législatives suffisantes
pour justement lutter contre le
terrorisme accueille depuis les
événements dramatiques de new york du 11
septembre 2001 on appris des tas de
mesures législatives la difficulté en
france et qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a
malheureusement un événement dramatique
et bien on va créer une nouvelle loi
sans même prendre le temps de faire le
bilan de la précédente on a quand même
eu la loi renseignement il ya quelques
temps qui a été prise maintenant on a
une nouvelle loi sur le terrorisme et le
financement du terrorisme et les règles
de procédure pénale qui est en débat
actuellement au parlement mais on ne
fait jamais l'inventaire de la loi
précédente
donc on accumule en accumulent et en
plus malheureusement la passion les
moyens non plus de nos ambitions ce qui
est un gros problème de la justice me le
dit monsieur le garde des sceaux hier
dans son interview au jdd
donc les autres solutions à mettre en
place si ce n'est pas pour faire de
nouvelles lois mais pour qu'elle
s'arrête elle se serait à mon avis déjà
de faire le bilan des lois qui existent
de pouvoir faire en sorte que ces lois
soient exécutés normalement et de donner
les moyens en amont à la justice et aux
services de renseignement de faire de
faire leur travail
ces empreintes de moyens financiers la
les syndicats de police déplore
justement ce manque de moyens financiers
ils ne sont pas suffisants sur les
territoires est ce que c'est la même
chose pour vous avec vous c'est
exactement la même chose quand vous
voyez le cri d alarme qui a été poussé
par mon homologue de bobigny il ya
quelques temps qui est repris
aujourd'hui par là par la chancellerie
c'est une réalité la justice
malheureusement en france est sinistrée
on sait que les français consacrent 61
euros par habitant et par an à leur
justice alors que dans d'autres pays qui
sont aussi comme nous
qui subissent les conséquences de la
crise se donne les moyens financiers
d'avoir une justice quand même qu'il
permette d'avancer
aujourd'hui la justice n'est -il
sinistrés il manque des personnels de
greffe il manque des magistrats les
dossiers s'accumulent et ne sont pas
traités donc ça pose aussi un problème
de crédibilité de l'institution
judiciaire
vous en appelez au gouvernement par
rapport à ces manques de moyens quelles
sont les réponses qu'on vous donne
peut-être à moi je pense qu'il ya
urgence c'est effectivement il ya un
état d'urgence mais il ya une urgence
pour la justice aujourd'hui à ce que
l'état prenne enfin la mesure de la
difficulté que rencontrent l'institution
judiciaire et se donne les moyens
d'avoir dans un état démocratique comme
le nôtre dans un état de droit après
avoir une histoire quand même au niveau
de ce que représente la france au niveau
du droit dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les moyens
nos ambitions donc oui le cri d'alarmé
je le pousse aujourd'hui je demande à ce
que et bien le budget de la justice soit
aujourd'hui à la hauteur de ce qu'il
devrait être dans un grand pays
démocratique
aujourd'hui dans l'actualité on parle de
la réforme pénale de l'antiterrorisme
elle est en discussion elle est
qualifiée de très rigoureuse
certains parlent même de mesures
liberticides vous votre analyse est ce
que cette réforme va trop loin
la réforme est encore en discussions
aujourd'hui et notamment va revenir au
parlement
il y à des mesures qui vont faire en
sorte que oui il peut y avoir des
atteintes aux libertés publiques aux
libertés individuelles à partir du
moment où on fait en sorte d'esquiver le
rôle du juge judiciaire gardien des
libertés individuelles et la présence de
l'avocat
aussi dans le cadre de ces procédures
puisque notamment il peut y avoir des
prétentions de personnes pendant une
durée de quatre heures sans qu'il y ait
nécessairement un avocat c'est la raison
pour laquelle la profession aujourd'hui
se mobilisent à l'occasion de
modifications du conseil supérieur
magistrature et d'une réforme
constitutionnelle pour faire en sorte
que la garantit le droit à l'avocat soit
constitutionnaliser aujourd'hui en
france comme ça se fait à l'instar de
grandes démocraties alors j'aimerais
qu'on vient de plus projet donc dans les
yvelines à versailles notamment le
procureur veut intensifier la lutte
contre la radicalisation est ce que vous
allez être consultés pour ces mesures
vous allez jouer un rôle aussi dans
cette approche
oui je pense que le barreau et les
avocats bien évidemment
leurs places à prendre je sais que
monsieur le procureur de la république
il a raison de le faire je veux
travailler sur ce terrain là et je pense
qu'on est au coeur l'a vraiment de la
difficulté d'aller dans les quartiers
d'aller dans les cités pour essayer de
voir ce qui ce qui se passe un petit peu
et d'essayer de faire en sorte de
comprendre pourquoi malheureusement tant
de jeunes qui sont français qui ont été
élevés ici qui partagent nos valeurs
aujourd'hui sont tentés par une aventure
complètement folle de partir ailleurs
pour faire ce que l'on a vu récemment
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi
travailler bien évidemment en amont pour
essayer de comprendre et bien évidemment
les avocats ont leur place dans ce
travail alors qu'elle quel rôle qu'elle
place comment vous allez peut-être joué
par rapport à ça ex pratiquement trail
expliquer ce qui est un état de droit ce
qu'est une les règles de vie collective
expliquer aussi ce qu'est la laïcité et
la place de la religion de manière à ce
qu'on puisse savoir faire en sorte qu'on
apprenne à vivre ensemble et ne plus
avoir à vivre les uns contre les autres
et c'est pour ça que je travaille à mon
avis ce sera très long à mettre en place
mais je pense qu'il peut porter ses
fruits notamment auprès des plus jeunes
car la lutte contre l'islamisme dont
clara l'occasion à est devenu une
priorité judiciaire 1 dans les yvelines
est-ce qu'il faut prendre plus de
précautions cela va peut-être changer
vos priorités également dans votre
mandat de bâtonnier oui il va y avoir
des orientations qui vont être
différentes et comme je voulais dit moi
je suis bâtonnier pour deux ans mais ça
se poursuivra bien évidemment après
parce que je pense que c'est un travail
de longue haleine un travail de terrain
où il faudra là encore donné les moyens
pour permettre à ces missions de porter
leurs fruits alors si on revient sur
votre rôle vous occuper également des
permanences penalty donc permettre aux
justiciables d'être représentée en
quarts en comparution immédiate devant
le juge d'instruction vous gérez les
litiges entre avocats mais aussi avec
les magistrats ou les clients et vous
vous occupez également des relations
avec le procureur le président du
tribunal comme de la cour d'appel et du
conseil des prud'hommes vous êtes élu
pour deux ans vous avez d'autres
priorités forcément que tu as d'urgence
au terrorisme où elles vont elles être
les priorités la priorité pour moi
aujourd'hui en tant que bâtonnier des
avocats du barreau de versailles qui
regroupe comme 750
avocat donc on a la chance d'avoir un
maillage territorial important sur le
département des yvelines
c'est de faire connaître le barreau de
versailles les compétences des avocats
que je représente aujourd'hui et pendant
ces deux années et de dire aux
justiciables car le besoin de droit dans
ce pays est immense il est énorme
de leur dire vous avez des avocats
compétents proche de chez vous donc
n'hésitez pas à aller voir ses avocats
ils sont formés ils sont disponibles et
ils savent ce sont quand même les
professionnels du droit
c'est l'avocat et pas un autre
professionnel donc rendre les avocats
finalement plus accessible pousser les
gens à peut-être pousser leur porte à
classer leurs portes à regarder sur les
sites internet également à prendre
contact avec l'ordre des avocats s'ils
ont besoin d'une consultation ou de
renseignement donc voilà il existe
aujourd'hui des tas de porte d'accès à
la profession d'avocat pour les
justiciables donc n'hésitez pas à aller
les voir pour ne serait-ce qu'une
consultation parfois une consultation
d'avocats permet de faire en sorte qu'un
litige va tout de suite reprendre la
place qui leur est due à voir et trouver
une solution amiable deux ans pour un
tel travail c'est suffisant il faut se
donner les moyens tous les jours pour
essayer de ne pas avoir de regret à la
fin
voilà donc je m'y emploierai merci
beaucoup à jean marc eder d'être venu
sur notre plateau et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
transporte maintenant la nouvelle
passerelle de la gare de versailles
chantiers est entré en service depuis
mardi matin 5 heures
elle devrait permettre de faciliter les
déplacements des milliers de voyageurs
qui transitent quotidienne
quotidiennement pardon par ce lieu
valérie pécresse a fait le déplacement
pour l'occasion un reportage signé fanny
bourdon
c'était devenu un cauchemar pour les
usagers depuis que la gare de versailles
chantiers étaient en travaux
la situation devrait désormais
s'améliorer mardi matin valérie pécresse
s'est rendue sur place pour la mise en
service de la passerelle 2 composée de
quatre escaliers mécaniques et de quatre
ascenseurs supplémentaires cette
passerelle va augmenter le confort des
voyageurs
ce qui est magnifique dans ces travaux
c'est c'est l'intelligence qui a été
mise
on s'est mis à la place du voyageur
comment simplifier la vie du voyageur
d'où vient-il
quel bus prend t-il en réalité c'est une
gare à visage humain c'est une gare qui
est parti de l'humain et je crois que ça
c'est très emblématique de ce qu'on doit
faire aujourd'hui avec les transporte
pas des transports déshumanisé mais les
transports profondément humaniste qui
font gagner du temps aux voyageurs mais
qui aussi lui offre des services avec 65
mille voyageurs et lille train qui
transitent ici chaque jour la guerre des
chantiers et la deuxième guerre la plus
importante de l'ouest parisien en termes
de flux vite saturé les travaux étaient
devenus indispensables ainsi qu'une
garde très emprunté comme vous le savez
et qui était devenue quasi saturé il
suffit de se rendre le matin aux heures
de pointe pour s'en rendre compte
donc la save à désaturer cette guerre et
qui est essentiel dans la logique du
grand paris le budget des travaux
s'élève à 65 millions d'euros dont la
moitié a été financée par la région ile
de france
mais le chantier n'est pas terminé les
travaux de rénovation et
d'agrandissement de la gare se
termineront en 2018 et il est temps à
présent de passer à notre chronique
environnement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
par dont nous allons parler de la
journée mondiale de l'eau et de
l'initiative d'un établissement yves
binois le collège jules verne aux
mureaux a sensibilisé pendant une
semaine ces élèves de 5e sur ce sujet
pour nous en parler en plateau avec nous
mais l'ani poker bon soir et la nuit il
sort floral alors vous l'a dit la
journée mondiale de l'eau c'était le 22
mars dernier ça a été initiée par les
nations unies pour célébrer leurs bleus
l'idée d'une semaine scolaire 100% est
venue de l'office du développement
durable des mureaux et de l' agence de
l'eau seine normandie placé sous la
tutelle du ministère de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie et
celui de l'économie
ces deux éléments ont proposé à elle
énervée professeur de sciences de la vie
et de la terre au collège jules verne
des mureaux d'organiser une semaine
thématique et nous en explique le but
l'idée c'est de les sensibiliser au
respect de leur environnement qu'ils
arrêtent de jeter des choses partout par
terre qui voit sa des conséquences sur
les autres êtres vivants sur les autres
humains et c'est une des formes pour
nous qui permettent de les sensibiliser
à la vie en groupe
voilà alors durant cette semaine ils ont
une programmation chargée ils ont
notamment découvert la station
d'épuration de la commune visiter un
appartement pédagogique ou encore
étudier une facture d'eau de cet
appartement jusque là ils ont aussi
visionner des films comme la soif du
monde de yann arthus-bertrand ils ont
été sensibilisés à la crue centennale
impossible des portes débordements
importants de la scène
ils ont réalisé des courts-métrages fait
des petites expériences autour des
arbres de leur importance dans ses
expériences notamment il modélise est
une forêt et de la farine et des
allumettes et ils simuler une pluie
violente pour voir ce que ça pouvait
donner
écoutez et l'énerver ça montre
simplement fait d'un simple point de vue
mécanique
fait d'avoir des végétaux plantés dans
le sol sans tenir quand même des de
toutes les interactions qu'il peut y
avoir entre les végétaux et le sol bien
ça retient le sol ça préserve le sol
donc l'idée bas ces deux gars étaient
bétonnées de plus comprenne bien
pourquoi c'est important d'arrêter de
bétonner de revégétaliser ce qui est en
train de se passer sur les murs ou alors
le public choisit ce sont des classes de
5e de l'établissement et ce n'est pas
anodin puisque l'eau est partie
intégrante de leur programme scolaire
l'eau est une thématique
pluridisciplinaire pour les 5e le cycle
de l'eau est étudiant en physique chimie
la vie des cours d'eau sur les paysages
7 en sciences de la vie et de la terre
et en histoire géo
il étudie les inégalités de l'accès à
l'eau alors on ne veut pas qu'ils ont
acquis beaucoup de connaissances pendant
cette semaine
alors cette semaine c'était une
vingtaine de professeurs et les quatre
classes de 5e de l'établissement soit 80
élèves
ils ont tous été sensibilisés mais le
plus simple pour voir ce qu'ils ont
retenu ces temps d'écouter quelques uns
ben j'ai appris que vous volez pas
gaspiller l'eau qu'on se brosse les
dents qu'on fait la vaisselle ou cause
douche j'ai appris que dans certains
pays à part de l'eau comme chez nous que
quand il prenait des heures ou 10
presque 10 minutes pour aller jusqu'à
loue depuis quand se laver dans on
laisse pas couler l'eau quand on ferme
on met deux un gobelet comme ça on ne
connaissent pas trop et qu'on fait la
vaisselle aussi présent pour la barre on
ne laisse pas le col et on n'utilise que
deux que pour des bonnes choses que pour
des bonnes raisons pour se brosser les
dents quand on a soif
quand slave moi j'ai appris que comment
l'ol elle passait dans les tuyaux etc
jusqu'à chez nous quelques passé dans la
douche et tous et qu'il faut partager
l'eau à travers le monde
et si vous aussi vous voulez vous
sensibiliser à la question de l'eau
rendez vous sur le site des nations
unies de nombreuses vidéos sont à votre
disposition pour découvrir toutes les
problématiques et toujours dans le thème
de l'environnement mais annie vous avez
un rendez vous à nous proposer
alors celui ci c'est l'association sky
en transition qui vous donnent rendez
vous
samedi 9 avril à partir de 14 heures
vous pourrez participer la création de
deux mini potager à magny les hameaux
pensez à vous inscrire pour participer
merci beaucoup mélanie et un dernier mot
de culture avant de refermer ce journal
vous les entendrez partout cet été
retenez bien ce nom c'est général
elektriks un groupe hors norme et
longeons tous les styles il était de
passage vendredi soit à la batterie 2 me
en cours fanny bourdon a assisté au
spectacle au regard des pop funk rock et
électro général elektriks un groupe au
style inclassable
hervé salters leader du groupe est fan
de synthés vintage aime mélanger les
genres tous que moi j'aime je mets ça
dans le sac et puis je secoue et je vois
ce que ça donne quoi et l'idée c'est de
de faire ça sans fond sur deûle snr les
morceaux et ne pas trop calculer
justement pour savoir si ça va faire un
morceau de rock de funk ou quoi mais
juste laisser partir c'est avec ce
morceau either with you que le groupe se
fait connaître du grand public en 2009
m
enfin
de nouveau son entêtant 2016 peut être
l'année de la confirmation pour général
elektriks avec leur quatrième album to
be et stranger un opus où hervé salters
parisien d'origine revient sur sa vie
d'expatrié j'ai ce sentiment d'avoir
perdu mes racines de ne plus appartenir
va nulle part qui est qui qui est un
sentiment imputé un petit peu et
grenoble c'est à dire qu'il y avait
quelque chose de très chouettes avec
saab se sent assez liban la sensation
d'être un petit peu de flotter en
observateur au dessus des choses et en
même temps ce sont un petit peu
nostalgique parce qu'on a on n'a plus
cette espèce de confort qui vient du
fait d'appartenir à quelque part quoi
vendredi soir à la batterie de
guyancourt le groupe était face à un
public conquis certains même les suivent
depuis leurs débuts on les a souvent au
bataclan ou à la cigale c'est pas des
scènes très très chouette d'aller voir
un côté comme ça pas cher bien ça bouge
bien et ça me donne très envie de
découvrir j'ai pas encore écouté dernier
album mais je préfère le découvrir sur
scène moi j'ai découvert
général elektriks il ya s'attend à la
clé les champs à plaisir et c'est le
coup de foudre c'est génial et depuis
j'essaye de voir tous les cas ça général
elektriks est en tournée jusqu'à fin
novembre
ils sont programmés dans de nombreux
festivals d'été dont les solidays le 26
juin prochain
une preuve qu'on n'a pas fini d'entendre
parler d'eux
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis à suivre au kiosque
votre magazine présenté par sephora
namani quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée